You are listening to radio lab radio from W N Y.
S. T. E.
So before we get started, I had a couple of questions for you. Yeah,
please fire away. So I've talked to a lot of people who leave, uh,
attempted to contact. Um, there's a lot of hesitation.
People just don't have faith in media right now and considering our issues,
um, to be honest, white controlled media.
So I got a couple of questions for you. Quest away. Um, why now?
Why do we want to do this story now? Yeah, it's been a couple of years. Um,
and it's, it's a, it's a, it's Abby. Abby, just found story.
So we, uh, we did, we were,
it was unknown to us until right now this feels a little newsy of the moment.
[inaudible] yeah, this is Robert, by the way. So we have Robert, we have,
we have Robert, we have jad. Jad j a d. D.
Yes. Yes. We should, I guess, do you have that? Did you have other questions?
Oh, sure. We can wait. We can table those. No, no, no, no. Let's hear them. Um,
so what is the end goal? What, what do you want the story to say?
We never know that.
Okay. Uh, Hey, I'm jabbing rod by. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and today today we're going to tell you the story of a guy.
It's just a guy named Ryan wash.
He's part of a movement of people who've taken this, um,
established corner of the, uh, academic world and they've,
they've reshaped it and reframed it into something
even weirder and more different. Weirder. Hmm. No,
well not weird bad beards. It's just interesting. Yeah. Interesting. Let's,
let's replay it. The worst weird, what's interesting? I don't know.
I'm just saying in debate lingo, that's a link. That's a link.
Um, usually when you run a criticism, the link is the,
the thing that they have done bad. Oh, okay. Okay.
Well the description, the description of performance debate is weird.
Is problematic. Well, can I, can I, can I put a list? Can I,
can I push mentally? Okay. So the world that we're talking about,
which is the center of this
whole story is obviously debate. Yes. High school debate and cause debate.
Now I have an inverted debates,
but from the outside it always seemed like this hyper competitive like brain
sport.
These guys were these little accordion briefcases where they have all these
files in there with all the research. Yeah.
And they go to these tournaments and they argue about some topic back and forth
and back and forth and back and forth. Yeah.
Now the interesting thing about debate, I didn't know this beforehand,
is that the people who do this often go on to become hugely powerful people.
You know, Supreme Court judges, presidents, leading thinkers, scholars,
titans of industry. It's the farm team of the big folks for tomorrow.
So Lee Iacocca from Chrysler, he was a debater. Margaret Thatcher, Ted Cruz,
Karl Rove, Hillary Clinton, Oprah Winfrey, Richard Nixon, Malcolm x,
they were debaters
today. This is Ryan's story. Ryan washes, story of debate.
Actually Ryan's story debating debate. Yes. Uh,
and the story comes from reporter Abigail Keel. And before we get going,
just one let you know there is some strong language in the story.
Some profane words, skip it if you need to. Otherwise. Here we go.
Is it cool if we jump in? Right? I would love to know Ryan.
Like what was your life like before you were ever on a debate team?
Well, Kansas City, Missouri, Inner City Public School, you know,
99% black students. I was actually tricked into debating.
I really had, when was it? When was this? We were talking about,
oh, well let me see. 2000, I'm sorry, I'm old.
2000 2005.
When were you born if you send your old 1990. Um,
but yeah, I, I ended up getting tricked into debate. Um,
I was definitely a more of an observant person,
which is why I like to play the game of chess because you know how people move
their pieces, the time it takes them to move their pieces all gives away,
you know, something their tails. Um, and so I was tricked into debate, um,
by playing chess.
And I ended up winning the school chess tournament that we had in this little
short German redhead lady named Jane Brown.
Hart came to chess practice. I ended up being President Chess Club.
She came to the chess practice one day and pulled me in the hallway and was
like, I understand, you know,
you were chance champion and that's a really good thing.
And we had this debate program and I think you'd be really good at it. Like, ah,
you know,
anybody who could critically think at chess could critically think and debate,
Yada, Yada, Yada. I didn't even know what debate was.
So he told her, no, no, not for me, but I persist.
So over the next year,
she kept on telling me, she was like, I thought I told you to join debate.
I thought I told you to join debate. And I was like,
I thought I told you to know I can spot a debater at 20 paces.
And she was just like, okay, you think I'm playing?
So one Monday I came to school, she handed me a piece of paper.
It was a revised schedule.
She had my schedule changed to where I had debate first hour
after. And so here I am. Here you are.
That's what happens with a lot of by debaters.
They just come and kind of dazed like, uh, my schedule got changed.
I'm like, yeah, okay, that's fine. Take a seat.
Those first few classes, Ryan's learning the basics of debate.
And in this kind of debate that he's doing, it's called policy debate.
There's two teams and two people on each team.
Usually the debate is about some kind of national policy topic.
Like the United States government should increase its economic engagement in
China.
One team at the beginning of the debate is randomly assigned to be affirmative.
And that means they're supporting that proposition. They're saying, yes,
the United States federal government should do that. Here's why. And
the other team is the negative team and they're arguing against the affirmative.
Both of those sides make their case. And then at the end
the judge decides who made the better arguments. I mean,
I get them up debating almost day one.
We ended up having a mock debates in class like Pepsi versus coke, you know,
family guy versus the Simpsons and stuff like that. So it wasn't very fun.
It made us learn how to do, um, impact analysis, impact analysis.
What is that? So for instance, let's say you're debating apples versus oranges.
If I say the rinds of apples are necessary for the fertilizer to produce
oranges, so you must vote for apples.
That would be the impact of choosing apples over oranges.
You have to be able to compare the two and make argumentation.
So the traditional center segmentation is Ryan started learning all of this
impact analysis Holeman to model argumentation when he started to devos path
logo. Do you really? Well, yeah, yeah, he did join the team,
started going to tournaments. You know,
debate is one of those activities that affords you the possibility of traveling
places where I grew up and went to school. I mean,
students didn't leave like a 40 block radius for their entire life. You know,
I mean, you're in control in that debate round
and,
and everybody's listening to you and I think it's important to feel that way,
even if it's only in a 60 90 minute debate round.
Ryan needed those wins he needed
it's power that allows enjoying the bed and that affirmation.
I was having a great time.
The thing that helped me out was that my first tournament was a debate.
Kansas City tournament debate. Kansas City is an urban debate league.
And so we were debating other kids from the same neighborhood,
just went to different schools.
And so that environment of debate was to me very different. Like, yeah,
we want it to win. But there was a lot more comradery in the debate I thought.
And so to me, by the time I went to my first national competition,
I was very much committed to debate.
But once I went to that national tournament for the first time, I was like, oh,
okay, I don't know about this. You know,
at national tournaments you're up against what I call name brand schools,
you know, like predominantly private schools.
And so we were real excited about that. Put our little dress clothes on,
got cute,
got on the bus nerves started kicking in a little bit just by going into a
debate tournament. We got off the bus, went inside and then
we went into the cafeteria
and when we opened the door to walk into the cafeteria and began to walk in
the room went silent.
I mean when I tell you the talking stopped,
literally 300 other plus students stopped and stared at us because a bus of
black kids had just arrived
and they like watched
us the whole time that we were in the cafeteria and they was like,
what are they doing here? Huh? Well at least that's how I felt, you know?
But we walked over to our table and our coach was like,
do not worry about them. Pull out your things, get warmed up,
get ready for competition.
And so got our stuff pulled out and started to practice and then they started to
whisper
[inaudible]
you know, whether they work Westbourne rap debate stuff were about us.
I don't know. I wasn't in Marriott,
but I can definitely explain to you what that felt.
It was real awkward and it was real uncomfortable
and making things even more awkward and more uncomfortable.
Is that when the debates actually got going,
and this is particularly true at the national level,
this is what debate sounds like because if it also turns back Walter's desertion
voluntary to get your costs and global nuclear war and escalation.
If there's a backlash,
the plan to use federal government through an act of Congress will potentially
inform domestic transportation infrastructure by requiring that all federally
funded European projects in the u s use 15 to 22% ground my boat and I split the
concrete mixes putting in for [inaudible] homes.
It's just like the intuitive, the sped up or something. No,
this is what debate sounds like today. Like they, they sort of speed read.
Well the goal of speed reading or spreading if you will,
is to get more arguments out.
[inaudible] structure has an urgent requirement for paradox
[inaudible] and this is like a quick digression that this kind of thing actually
started in like the 1960s and the students were actually the ones who were
driving it.
One of the things that makes debate such an interesting intellectual game is
that it's much more of a bottom up driven activity than a top down activity.
That's Scott Harris, director of debate at the University of Kansas.
In the case of speed reading,
we evolved a situation where one team decided, well,
I'm going to present eight arguments and the other team talked slower and only
answered six of them. And the judge says, well,
you didn't answer two of these arguments so you lost the debate because you
didn't answer those rookie butts. Well,
we need to answer all eight of those arguments.
And they started to talk faster and the other team said, well,
we'll present 10 arguments and then they answer 12 and then they bid.
And so it escalated to a point. Um,
in some instances has gone way too far. Right.
And getting back to Ryan,
it's not as if he didn't know how to do that style of debate.
That's the way I debated. I did try to speak fast,
but he says somewhere around the first national tournament,
like all that stuff just kind of stopped making sense to him.
Like the fast talking and the fact that he had to debate these super, you know,
Highfalutin topics. Um,
I felt as if I could never take any of the stuff that I learned in debate and
take it back to 33 Oh four ASCII, which where I live,
and this isn't just unique to Ryan.
I mean what you see at this stage in debate is that a lot of kids,
like especially inner city kids from public schools, black students, you know,
they just start to drop out of debate at a certain point.
But Ryan Ryan didn't do that.
Something big is going to happen.
I have a feeling like somebody's going to say no, no, no.
What happened was is that a student from university academy, she was a senior,
her name was marsh Shauna and she went to a different school than Ryan. Um,
she came over and asked around heart. She needed a partner.
There was about to be this tournament called the KC KCC TLC tournament.
It was a big high school debate tournament and Marshana she was a senior,
so she was older than Ryan, but she needed a partner.
So she came to Jane Rinehart and Jane said, well, uh, here, Ryan,
he's your guy. So met with Marsha,
it was the Thursday before the tournament happened and I pulled her into this
room and I had Oprah, I had three boxes of evidence, you know,
and I was ready to go with my traditional stuff.
The topic was whether the US should increase participation in national service
programs. So like peace corps, armed services, stuff like that. So now I'm like,
oh, this is the stuff that I've been working on.
I showed her the learning center of America stuff.
I had this like Peace Corps affirmative that I hadn't wrote yet.
You should are note cards with statistics on them, quotes from various experts,
you know? And she was like, yeah, that's cute. Yeah.
And so she handed me this expando and it was just like, okay, take this folder,
go home, study it.
So I got home and I opened this expando and it was all of this,
it was full of things. And I stayed up literally all night
studying this file. I mean, it was not a lot of evidence.
There was not a lot of pre written out answers to arguments.
There wasn't a lot of that. There was some things that were,
there was Ralph Ellison's. I am an invisible man. Uh,
there was a clip from Ralph Ellison's invisible man in there. There was, um,
you may write me down in history with your bitter twisted lies, uh,
my Angelou poem in there.
You may trod me in the very dirt but still like dust out.
There was some original stuff that she wrote and I'm like, I,
I didn't get it, but she was the seniors. Sorry. Reinhart kind of told me,
you know, let her, you know, drive the ship. You just ride along.
And I was like, okay. So next day we get to the first debate.
I still was very unclear when we arrived at the tournament,
just what was going on.
He and Shauna get to the classroom and standing on the other side of the room.
Are there two opponents? Are they white kids? Mostly, yeah,
they were white guys in suits were republican ties on.
If you want to know if you want to visit, just finish the other team,
their affirmative. So they go first and they're like
[inaudible] blah blah, blah.
They lay out this whole argument about how the national service programs are
good because they increase your as power abroad and then it was more Shauna's
turn. So she gets up to give this speech and it starts with this like
four minute long piece of spoken words like this performative speech kind of
about her personal experience in debate.
And if she had this way of speaking that was very passionately forceful.
It made stop. They stopped writing, they stopped talking.
Okay.
And in the middle of this riff Marshawn, I laid out this argument.
That's the style of debate that they engaged in.
That fast paced form of debate was exclusionary because it demotivated minority
students from participating. And not only that,
like it also creates this resource and balance because if you're going to start
debating with a ton of arguments,
then you have to research that many arguments and you need help researching
those arguments.
So you pay people and you pay coaches to help you make those arguments.
And that clearly favors rich and affluent schools. And beyond that,
Marshawn argued like even the language itself sets up a norm of what counts as
intelligent, authoritative argumentation, for instance,
like men's voice to be held over women,
black people to always seem angry and brewed, um,
when they're just being passionate, as if they don't have feelings. You know,
it was a criticism of the auctioneer style of debate.
It was a criticism of the insular lingo of debate.
It was a criticism of the way in which debates were decided socially and
politically as opposed to argumentatively.
So I was like, I was like, okay,
I can tell you shot did this shock. You know, I w I wasn't shocked.
I was like, Eh. I was like, on one hand I was like, Damn,
that was a grace that was tight snaps.
Like we was at the poetry slam, but I was sitting to myself thinking like, okay,
how am I going to extend this? Like when it got to be his turn,
what's left for him to say, I don't know what more,
what other words I could use.
And so it wasn't until the second person from this team got up and he started to
speak and he was like, you know, debating about the seat is great.
[inaudible] this is a, this, this is disrespectful to the state of debate.
And he turned to her,
it was this moment he turned to her and he said it like from his soul,
you should go down the hall because that's where poetry pros has helped.
This is academic debate. I was like, what?
And he basically, his argument was that what we were doing was not in debate.
We, what we were having with a talent show is how he described it.
And I was just like, I, I get it. I,
and maybe it was the study and I had done all night,
but everything kicked in in that moment where the passion came into the room.
What was it like?
I get everything that she was trying to say what she was saying about the
structure of debate because I had felt those things before.
I just didn't know how to articulate them. Was it like I get that I can,
was it like permission? Was she saying like the Betas? Fuck that. I'm sorry.
And let's just say we definitely went on to win that debate. You won this match.
Yeah, we won the debate because, okay,
so let me just explain like what happened in this debate. Um,
judges on already in this kind of situation have a choice, right?
Like they can hear the arguments that Ryan Marshawn are making
and they can think, uh, okay,
this isn't really about the peace corps or about armed services.
So you lose, or they can do what the judge in this debate did.
And they can say, all right, this topic has kind of shifted,
but let's look at what we have in front of us.
Let's look at the arguments that were made.
You Have Ryan and Marshawn is saying that the structure of debate is racist.
And then you've got the other team not really responding in any kind of like
counter argumentative way. And Ryan in this debate, what he does is he,
he points at that,
he points it when this other team says leave the room and he says, Hey,
like what they just did proves our point that we are excluded from debate and
the judge agreed.
Oh, so you use, you use his sort of, you used his,
you don't belong here as a kind of as a, as an [inaudible].
And that's when I was saying it's about our evidence and came for a lot from
what happened in the debate process. Fascinating. [inaudible] wait, is it like,
let me just take that guy side like so that you're changing the whole, the,
you're throwing their huge bombs at them. Racism.
Hegemony like what's he supposed to do? Say I'm a racist, I'm going to be,
what is he supposed to do?
Like what do you mean stop or first off do he should stop
second alpha. I mean,
you don't have to say you're racist.
Ain't nobody gonna want to admit that they're racist.
But you can definitely admit that you've engaged in racist practice or you can
have a debate about whether or not that was a racist practice.
There's a healthy debate to be had about that.
But instead what he said was that you all do not belong here. Leave the room.
[inaudible]
like if you walk in and you say what you just said and you say it forcibly and
eloquently and the other says, hey, you're changing the rules here.
You're breaking things down. No, to leave the room.
And then in the leave the room,
they leave themselves open to this counter attack that you give. It's still,
it still surprises me that you win.
And so this was the thing, there's very few rules to debate,
but there's tons of norms and depending on, you know,
the community of debate of the space of debate that you're in,
those norms may differ. But I only know of a few rules.
Like there must be a winner and a loser, a time limits.
And I've seen that be debatable at times. Um,
there must be an affirmative and a negative. Other than that.
How one approaches debate, you know, how one approaches the topic,
how one approaches themselves in their opposition.
All of that stuff is debatable and arguably should be debatable. What is it?
There's no like Bible of the, of debate. There's no like book.
It's like, okay so they put out things like the NDT rule book,
which is like affirmative teams must be topical, but in the world of debate,
what does it mean to be topical? You know, what does it mean to be on topic?
Wow. That has to be debatable in order for
[inaudible] this is getting good. Interesting.
I'm just curious if you're really good at this,
like can you give me part of me what you would have said if you were the guy
coming after you or before you,
well I'm one of the things that they needed to do in particular was to say that
the bait itself shouldn't be about debate. They were trying to say that,
but what they said was y'all should leave a c. That's interesting. Say.
Cause cause that's one of the,
the place where I have sympathy for the other side is, is where they're like,
yeah, I thought we were talking about the Peace Corps.
Like they walked into the wrong room or something. The other,
but that was one of our argument. It was that how do you do debate?
How do you participate in an activity for hours and hours and hours and weeks
upon weeks upon weeks that arguably years are years and years and not ever think
about why you debate the wave at you do that.
We'll what we were present. So what, what was the other team's reaction?
They were really upset. Um, yeah, they called us an inward and shit. No.
So really? Yes. Like what do you mean? No, that's
[inaudible] we'll be right back.
This is Ms. Smith calling from her eighth grade history classroom.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information about Sloan at www dot Sloan dot. Yeah,
Lord.
Hey guys, this is Alison calling from Luxembourg.
Radiolab is supported by rocket mortgage by quicken loans.
Rocket mortgage brings the mortgage process into the 21st century.
With this completely online process safely share your bank statements and pay
stubs with the touch of a button.
Ditch the paperwork and use your phone or tablet to get approved for purchase or
refinance in minutes.
Get a custom mortgage solution whenever and wherever you want.
Check out rocket mortgage
today@quickenloansdotcomslashradiolabequalhousinglenderlicensedinallfiftystatesandnlsconsumeraccess.org
number 30 30 hi this is Mckenna Anderson at the University of South Florida.
Currently in the woman's laboratory,
Radiolab is supported by Poopourri the before you go toilet spray.
The good folks at Poopourri once reminded that using the restroom for 10 minutes
each day at work equals 40 hours a year. Hey,
that's like an extra week of vacation.
So is it [inaudible] dot com to find out how you can go anywhere with confidence
even@workintothediscountcoderadiolabfortwentypercentoffatpotpourri.com see ya.
Hey, I'm John [inaudible]. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and it's back to our story again from producer Abigail Keel,
which is a story about a guy named Ryan wash and about debate.
How we debate. Yeah. Okay.
So just to kind of like pull back from that moment with Marsh Shauna and the
poetry and all that, this kind of thing wasn't just happening in a vacuum.
Like it actually came from all kinds of different places all at once. And
one particular interesting person who was influencing it was George Soros with
the billionaire. Yeah.
Soros Soros was fascinated by debate. Dr Shannera read wrinkly,
she's a scholar and a big figure in the so called black debate world.
Saros thought that debate was one of those kinds of activities that was
incredibly important to the production of democracy.
So he started funding debate programs overseas and say places like Eastern
Europe and here in the u s he poured tons of money, like
millions and millions and millions of dollars to start urban debate programs.
First started with New York City, 1997 right.
So they literally, you know, went out to all of these New York high schools,
talked to a bunch of administrators and sorrows,
just pumped money into a New York City to start an urban debate league.
And then it went to Baltimore and then to Chicago,
Detroit went to Kansas city out to La Newark
and it just kept moving. So we're almost up to maybe 23 or 24 city.
So you know, if you take a step back and look at it all like suddenly,
really within just a few years you have all of these new black debaters and many
of those students she says would go through the exact same thing that Ryan went
through
at the regional level.
You can imagine you get a bunch of African American students,
a bunch of teachers who are supporting them in a very positive environment.
They build relationships and friendships.
And so debate feels like home in that space.
But as soon as they go to that first national tournament culture shock because
there is a sea of white people and according to Dr. Reed Brinkley,
this influx of black debaters into a primarily white space started to create
some tension and pressure and that all built up and eventually resulted in
something called Baloo evil project. The Louisville Project, um,
started its goal was to increase a meaningful participation like Louisville,
Louisville. What happened? And let us go back
[inaudible] I know that there's a baseball bat. [inaudible] okay. So,
um, early two thousands, uh, down at the University of Louisville,
there was a debate team, a predominantly African American team. Um,
and so they were having a hard time finding traction. You know,
he says they would go to these national tournaments and you know,
no matter what they did,
if they tried to accommodate them more traditional stout,
there was always something that they did wrong.
Apparently those students would try to make arguments about race inside the
topics, but usually it didn't work.
And so at a certain point or they decided that they were done with that,
they were like, no,
we are unwilling to play your game in the way that you have defined it should be
played. And so these debaters,
what they would basically do is they would show up and they would force a
conversation about race, basically saying like,
we're not going to talk about China or global trade until we deal with this.
This is always bill's famous sprays.
They said we can't change the state but we can change the state of debate.
So they kind of ended up developing this whole new methodology,
which is actually a throwback to Aristotle and in his idea, yeah,
you need three things to persuade someone. Ethos,
pathos and logos. Logos is like logic. So, um,
you know, getting research and scholars and evidence and things like that path,
those, that's where emotion comes in.
So maybe a personal story or sharing something that will connect with the
audience and then ethos, which is kind of hard to pin down.
You can think of it like as credibility. Um,
or it's sort of like speaking in tune with like the spirit of your culture.
That's where you get the introduction of the use of hip hop,
the Sweden to CSA, the doctor, the flashing that the police, the spoken words,
they say the N****s always already queered that's exactly the point.
It means that,
and it's the case turn to the affirmative because we're seeing the use of what
we call street scholars.
[inaudible]
you know, what was the reaction when this first started?
They would say things to Louisville like, you know, this isn't research.
This is me.
Search as if black scholars noted black scholars in their field are not real
experts, right? They would say things like, hip hop does not belong here. Um,
your argument style doesn't belong here. And they,
and then I'm saying these things and really nice ways, you know what I mean?
But there could be really angry, screaming matches at tournaments.
Would you have a, an objection to a prohibition as a coach? If you said like,
look for the next year,
let's never talk about you and leave you or a gender, your sex,
your background, your family,
your religion behind and stay entirely in the brain. I quit.
I doubt that you would do that, but I'm wondering why you wouldn't.
I would, well, I think that's anti-black. Oh, I think it's anti black too,
Sandy. Everything. It'll be Andy Gay, Andy, you and [inaudible].
Right, exactly. It would be anti all of those things,
but particularly for our purposes, right. It's, it's, it's,
it would be anti-black and the reason why that's important for me is because
these students don't get to leave their blackness at the door when they enter
for competition. Right. They can pretend that they're not black,
but that does not mean that everybody else is going to pretend that they are not
black. How even when they speak,
what arguments they make when they open their mouth to make an argument,
people are paying attention to the fact that it is coming out of a black body.
They don't get to speak without race being a factor.
Nobody gets to speak without being a factor in a nation where race is a factor.
Now back to Ryan.
So he's 16 years old and he sees Marshawn and do this spoken word poetry thing,
starts to read more about Louisville and he's just like, I'm in
that. I dedicated my debate career to discussing debate, every debate, every,
every single one, every single one. Fast forward
he graduated high school, isn't sure he's going to go to college.
I was a first generation college student,
so I really didn't know much about the process. But then early August,
2008 he gets a message from a debate coach at a small school in Kansas called
Emporia state university.
And August 14th I was driving up to Imparja for college.
So Ryan gets there, it gets paired up with a sophomore, Lotoja, Williams Green,
who's now the director of debate at cal state Fullerton go best for him.
Two of them start debating together and over the course of a couple of years,
Ryan starts to get recognized.
Um, he's winning speaker awards. He's, you know,
making it into the out rounds at tournament.
But it was an uphill battle.
She says that Ryan kept bumping into judges who weren't really into the whole
three tier approach to debate. Yes, I lost it.
A lot of debates before I won any of them. And at this point,
toy has graduated and he's debating with the freshman on the team.
He's halfway into his senior year when,
um,
I had their freshman's new debate partner flunked out of school at this point.
It was either find somebody to debate with or it might've been career with over
[inaudible].
And so what happens, uh,
is Ryan is also close to one of my best friends who's one of my contemporaries.
Um, Rashad Evans who was then a coach at western Connecticut University.
And Basically Rashad had this bombshell idea. He,
one day they called Ryan up and they were like about asking,
what if you partnered up with this guy from Rutgers, Elijah Smith?
And the reason I'm particularly Rashad, I thought this was a good idea. First,
Elijah is within a standardly good debate or he just had excellent skills and
traditional skills. But the other reason was that, uh,
both Ryan and Alijah were queer black men.
The thinking was that you've got two guys kind of standing at the intersection
of to like marginalized groups and if they're going to try to make an argument
about feeling excluded and invisible in the debate world,
well they can own that argument
better than almost anyone. So I called him one night,
it was nine 30 and he's like, Hey, do you want to come debate with me?
And he was like, dude, this is a lot. I can't really answer this right now.
And I was like, I understand.
I'm asking you to come move to Kansas for a semester or what have you.
And Liam Newark from Newark, New Jersey. Um,
he called me back the next morning. Uh, it was like 8:00 AM my time.
And he was like, I've already applied and everything.
And so within the next couple of weeks he was down in Emporia,
Elijah and I debated four tournaments together.
First tournament they won two matches.
Last four. I was very upset. I was, because I was a senior and I was like,
I don't really do two, four but it's fine. You know, it's okay.
Dr. Reed Brinkley was actually at that tournament and she said that watching
Ryan and Elijah debate was a hot mess because they just didn't have any
chemistry.
There was nothing persuasive about, and nothing popped about it, you know,
it didn't really speak to the judges.
She remembers a time when Ryan came over to her apartment to talk to her and
Rashad
and then he was just like, you know, I don't know what we're doing wrong.
You know, he, he, you know, he just didn't know why things weren't clicking.
What's not working. I don't know what's happening.
So the three of them were all talking and Rashad like,
Ryan really looks up to Rashad because Rashad is also a queer black guy,
but he's also like a really, really great debater.
And, uh, it was, um, Rashad who said,
you're not being a queer black man. Right? You're being a debater.
And so Rashad would say things like, you need to butch it out.
You know what I mean? You need to, you know, you need to fem it up sometimes.
Sometimes you need to duck walk on him. You know what I mean?
Sometimes you're going to have to vogue, you know, so he's saying be black.
You will always be black and queer in these spaces.
So rather than attempting to hide parts of yourself, uh, instead,
you should be fully you.
Ryan with this and his head went back to Elijah and within a few weeks
things started to click who were just like, here's what our roles are.
This is what you do. This is what I do.
This debate is about to make the performance and megawatts for clues perpetuated
by the negative to the crop. I would start the debate argument, thank you.
To propagate the strategy that allows for up tonight.
You can meet those N****s that you think is the most, to me,
Ryan would preach black and rain in the choir, if you will.
[inaudible] structural inequalities that allowed the hood to be segregated and
then Elijah your office, like our art,
he did the middles to beaches. He dealt with logic, counterarguments,
things like that.
It was a question of black goals of persons who pistol biologist.
He was better at the game of debate.
Ryan said they went from practicing ethos, pathos, logos to being,
we embodied that methodology, how their methodology, literally
your problem. Then I will end the debate that the sit,
the armor that talks about real talk you are
and their second tournament,
they made it to the finals and they lost in a close decision,
but their third tournament was actually a national tournament called Sita
cross-examination debate association.
It's Kinda called that people's Tournament and they won that tournament.
I was able to give a pretty good two ar and we ended up squeaking the debate out
and then their fourth tournament, their final tournament together.
That's actually, it's the whole reason we're telling this story. It's the NDT,
the national debate tournament.
That was the tournament. Why decision not to go for framework with Freddie?
Kimra MDT is this marathon of a debate tournament. Oh,
like you know, March
madness or something. It's held every year.
It lasts for four whole days and there's 13 rounds of debates,
78 teams. The MDT is where
Harvard is northwest area, you know,
Georgetown,
so tournament that they prepare for. That's the tournament.
Those sorts of teams usually win. So
we were definitely the underdogs. Definitely the underdogs.
An all black team had never gotten past quarter finals of this tournament.
Things kick off Friday morning at 8:00 AM in Poria versus
Idaho State and they beat Idaho State at 11:45 AM they take care of Puget sound,
four 15 they go against Oklahoma. Oklahoma
beats them, but it's Prelim, so it's not like they're out or anything.
And then the crazy thing is that after the loss to Oklahoma,
Ryan and Elijah going on
role, they take down USC, they rollover Emery, they beat not one,
but two different teams from harbor. They beat Michigan State.
And then on the last day they beat another team from the University of Michigan.
Then they go on to be wake forest that puts them in the SMEs,
which has never been done before by a black team.
And then they're against Oklahoma who they beat. And that
puts them into the finals. It was, I can't,
everything's very surreal to me. We're in the finals of the MDT.
A never happened before.
We're also PR potentially about to unite the crowns.
And what that means is when seat in the NDT,
no team in history had ever done that. And, and who were they up against?
Well,
they were going against a team that Ryan had already faced like twice that year
and lost every time.
The 14 time national debate champions,
Northwestern university.
So when this round gets set up between Northwestern and in Poria,
one of the things that we've described it as is a clash of civilization.
She says that about Northwestern because they have one of the biggest debate
programs in the country. They've got an entire hive mind,
you know, with a hotel war room for sure.
Them to strategize, strategizing. And then
it was us, these two queer black guys from Emporia, Kansas
from a really small school with not a lot of resources.
So it is like a David and David and Goliath story.
Okay. So let me explain the room to you. I,
this is the biggest room that I had ever debated in this hotel room that they
have the debate happening in is a huge ballroom.
Welcome to the final round of the 2013 and this ballroom was packed.
[inaudible] but
the audience itself is segregated on the right side of the room.
Northwestern side. It was packed full of their people. And then on our side,
was it like racially segregated too? It was, it was. It was.
So just to round the
judges for this evening's debate
up near the front of the room at a table where the judges,
which included our guys, Scott Harris. Yep.
And how many judges were judging this debate? Five. Four men.
One woman for all of them or what?
And he forgives. Even tonight's debate will be that Universal Ryan
and Elijah from Aporia,
they were on one side of the stage and on the other side of the stage are the
two Northwestern students wearing our Northwestern jerseys. One was this guy,
m Arjun Valley [inaudible]. I debated at Northwestern for four years.
And the other was his partner, a young woman named spangly Peyton Lee.
I don't know if she knew this, but she was like my college debate nemesis,
my partner Peyton, I was a sophomore. Um, whereas my partner and uh,
Ryan were on the other side were seniors.
And that was the thing that was really getting me,
it was going to be my last debate. It was Peyton's last debate.
It was my last debate. We were seniors. This was it. Oh Wow.
College debate is the pros. It's the NFL. It's it.
Since it's their last debate,
everybody kind of gets up before their speeches to say like, thanks and bye
I to [inaudible] for [inaudible] again,
this is Ryan. Yup.
This is going to be my back. So it might take you a little bit. Um,
this is Peyton to be his good buddy can lead my Krebs.
It's been my hardest work and my most rewarding play. Um,
and it's taught me more than I could ever treated, um,
for that aim intended to all of you,
every part of this community in particular,
number special people. If I like it.
Wow. It was, it was a lot.
So the topic for the year was whether or not the United States federal
government should increase incentives for certain forms of alternative energies.
I was nuclear power, solar power,
wind or reduced restrictions on other forms of alternative energies, coal,
natural gas, and oil.
Okay, so Ryan and Elijah were affirmative,
so they were supposed to argue like something positive about the how the u s
government should support solar energy production or should restrict coal usage
and energy or whatever. But they're not going to debate that.
But we had figured out that we had wanted to talk about the ideal home.
In other words,
energy isn't the most important conversation that we need to have.
The conversation we need to have is whether this community can include people
like Ryan, like Elijah, can we find home and debate
because that's how the community feels about itself,
that this is a home place for a lot of people, right?
There are people who grew up in debate,
people who started debating when they were 12 and 13 when all the way through
college.
So the people that you often develop the tightest with people that you know how
some of your coolest memories cause you all spent the summer together going to
debate camp. Those people make up your family.
There are people who make friends and debate when they're 13 that they keep
until they die.
So Ryan's up first and to make his argument about home,
he bought the records, the great formerly of the canned reports.
He told them no place like home even look at the pot.
He starts talking about a movie.
Have you all seen the ways I have? I have not. Okay, so
all right, real quick synopsis.
It's a 1978 film and what it is is like an all black cast version of the wizard
devise. So like Michael Jackson is playing the scarecrow.
Richard Pryor is the Wiz and Diana Ross is Dorothy.
It was that movie was just like to me, you know, it was the fear that Dorothy,
yeah,
the beginning of arriving to eyes.
Then [inaudible] us. I want to go home.
I mean the point Ryan's making is that like that's how he felt too when he came
into debate when he was walking into that cafeteria. Yeah. Yeah.
And there's a line where you say,
let me find a,
when the Dorothy's of this world think of energy,
they don't think of three m reactors,
but the energy required to get out of bed and navigate the struggle. Yep.
So that's like kind of how, is that how you were like tying it?
Yeah. Energy for us meant what it meant to get out of bed in the morning.
What it meant to thrive in a world in which you were never meant to survive.
And for Dorothy, she was able to reach a place of eyes. Please.
Is there a way for me to get home where you realize that all you ever needed in
the first place was yourself inside me and that you had the power all along.
And that's part of what our argument was.
And that was part of what I was trying to say was that I had been in debate for
eight years at that point and I was so sick and tired of people telling me that
what I had to say about debate and what I thought about debate wasn't legit when
debate was a student driven activity that I have just as much to say about this
topic as you do and your claims are not any more valid than mine and vice versa.
And Ryan ended his like eight and a half minute speech on sort of this like
hopeful appeal, you know, to never give up. You know,
we have to ease on down the road together. Dorothy just can't go by herself.
You know,
maybe I had much older, the fat guy in the crop. Oh, she did have one thing,
Brian and that no place like, Huh
[inaudible].
And then after a few minutes origin the sophomore from Northwestern,
I got up and I gave the first negative speech
[inaudible] you started to make these arguments,
the one that they had beat us with every time called, which basically
says the topic has posited a question, you know,
you should the US government alter its approach to energy policy and we think
that the affirmative should have to answer that or this isn't a real debate.
Well first of all, I don't think the resolution is a question. Second of all,
like nowhere in the rules is it say that you have to be topical, but
our position was debates should be theoretically fair.
Both sides should be able to win.
And if you're going to come out here and argue that racism is bad,
debates on a home, like we can't argue against that.
I'm not going to say debate isn't a home for me. I love it.
It's not fair to have to argue against that.
Just who is debate here for now? Whose debate inclusive Fordham.
Now is it actually fair if in order to win a debate you need to have like a
whole research team and debate camps that cost thousands of dollars to
participate in. But
there's a topic that's democratically voted upon by all the schools at the
beginning of the year.
Something about the topic should be mentioned just to give the negative
basically respect
[inaudible]
respect for the thousands of hours that my partner and I in the Northwestern
debate team and other people in debate have spent researching energy and being
prepared to talk about the intricacies of energy policy in the United States.
This went on for over an hour. I mean it was, it was a lot happening
and eventually Arjun and Peyton really start to like focus their argument on
like their version of debate, the traditional version.
This is how you actually change the world.
Not by focusing on yourself but doing research.
It's being able to argue the fermentative side of something and the negative
side of it, because people who learn those kinds of skills,
they can actually go and do things outside of debate,
like deal in convoluted, globalized trade negotiations or solve global warming.
Right. So after two hours of this, it's almost midnight.
Ryan feels like exhausted.
Um, yeah. But I felt it in the room that people were like,
we're not out of the debate. We can still win at this point.
There's only one speech left and it's Ryan's. I was nervous.
I knew it was my last speech.
I knew everybody in the audience was waiting on me.
Like I just felt pressured and I had maybe five sentences written on a piece of,
you know, just copy paper.
And I looked over at Elijah and kind of was just like, Whoa, this is it.
This is it. That's all I got.
The audio quality of this speech is kind of terrible, but um,
we're just gonna let it play.
Hold on. The garden in this debate for you to vote of the team
[inaudible] will be bracing back home.
I don't think they have really answered this.
Uniqueness arguments that are not allowing their debates,
all their evidence that suits the role of a good citizen case suits in
democratic societies.
All of the things assume that people played people [inaudible] discussion of the
assets are in the right to have a hold of a first place black wall about our up
in bed, wake themselves in a moment of
reflecting that enables them to speak out as a way to engage and change our
relationship to the world and I'll go to ourself,
which means that regardless of whether or not we're using the tools of the
[inaudible]
and Ryan says like early on that piece of paper he was holding, I like through
the weekend we start speaking from my soul, what I will call the Shonda,
the Shonda,
the Shonda is the place that encapsulates your soul laying in your loins.
Well, all right.
Probably not. They are calling about Robert. The question, rob,
do we get the first bottle ever?
When do we have a discussion around we go into
[inaudible] or close individuals.
We have already had access to a whole organ to go through
[inaudible] together. Willy, the whole hand
off to Michael Jackson to leave on down the road together,
which is exactly what Arthur did, did a laptop.
[inaudible] integrates to the question of I don't want it.
Instead of being in their notions apparent is one that is always
[inaudible] now. Now it's still,
we don't now why do I have to make a for soil?
Why do I have a a date another team?
Yeah.
Especially when they don't have another place to go.
When did they have been the place where I can share my perspectives in the team
would probably keep it.
I don't know what of what I would do when this debate is over.
I don't know how long
[inaudible] energy production do what it needs to get out of bed in the morning.
Who was
[inaudible]
so there was portions of the speech that I don't remember giving,
which is like apparently I, there was a part where I almost took my shirt off,
shirt off and then like I don't remember that.
And I had a pause cause what I was trying to just get out of that zone.
I'm in comeback, it's a kind of like provide a voice of reason.
But as I kind of slowed down to do that, but the crap
[inaudible] I have
50 seconds left. I still have to answer this last thing.
I still have to extend this piece of evidence. Oh Shit.
I didn't say anything about warming. What do I do? What do I do?
Am I doing ever since like, I don't know, this is reason enough to vote.
Affirmative. Forget it.
[inaudible] and then
I walked over and shook their hands.
Um, I gave Elijah hug and then I walked out the room and went and smoked a
cigarette.
At that point as a judge, I took a deep breath, uh, packed up my notes.
I put headphones, noise canceling headphones on my head. Um,
I found a room where there was no one else around and I could have total quiet
and think about what had been said.
Nope. Scott says that he felt like the debate was close, like
there's going to be a tight vote. So I sit down and look at my notes.
I relisten to the last couple of speeches that I had recorded several times.
On one hand Northwestern presented a lot of good research and a lot of it he
agreed with. On the other hand,
like Peyton and Arjun are saying if you have these skills then you're going to
be better prepared to go talk in front of like Congress or something.
But Scott says if you just listen to like Ryan and Elijah,
like they sound more persuasive.
Like you can't convince me that somebody who sounds like that isn't actually
also prepared to do those things. And so like Ryan and Elijah,
his whole presentation is actually proof that Peyton and origins argument is
invalid. At the same time, he thought
there have to be things that we all just agree on as our starting point
and if the alternative is a world in which the affirmative can come into a
debate and talk about anything they want to talk about, um,
then the ability to make that a fair competitive environment seems a little
problematic.
I think Scott was kind of torn.
It took me about 45 minutes to an hour to decide
who I thought won the debate.
Ryan says that when he was sitting there waiting for the decision to be
announced, I was very convinced that we lost and eventually
they announced those decision three two decision.
Three judges voted from Poria in two for Northwestern [inaudible] for three to
four, the affirmative from Emporia. Yet
what
[inaudible] my partner Elijah jumped out. He's like, yeah,
the people are crying. I mean, if you could have seen this
room erupts into joy.
I was in tears watching this historic moment happen because I'd been around for
so long and I'd watched so many black debaters fail to make it to that top
point. I stood there and I was like,
oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God.
All I can say, I said it like a million houses. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God.
Oh my God. Yeah. What swayed Scott in the end?
Well, he actually published this like 11 page. I say all about, you know,
his decision explaining why he voted the way he did. Um, there's a lot in there,
but what I kind of take away from it is that, you know,
while while maybe he didn't like that there was a sort of disregard for the
topic,
he would have liked it a whole lot less if Ryan and Elijah hadn't been in the
room.
I mean, debate is itself, is incredibly important to me.
A debate has been the greatest influence in shaping who I am as a person.
Um,
and so in many ways I view debate as my home and given that it was a debate that
challenged and criticized the activity that I have made a home for the last 40
years that pointed out weaknesses,
it caused me to reflect whilst their argument really worked,
I find this kind of hike. It's,
it's either a segregating or an integrating event.
My Gavitt Mike senses that as kind of integrating like interracially chili
world. This is a strangely warm spot.
Are you saying? No. Well, right.
You know, when we asked Ryan about how he felt about winning this tournament,
I expected him to be really like celebratory and you know,
tell me that it changed his life.
He was the first black student to win this tournament. And you know,
it seemed important to me, but he didn't really go there.
No, you still don't seem like as proud as I want you to see him. You know,
like why, why no,
you know, I, you know,
it was a good thing for history. Um,
it was a good thing to motivate people. I just,
I just want to stay focused. It was an important, when it was significant,
it was powerful. It was beautiful,
but it was very clear to us very early on that not much had changed by the time
we got into the next year.
Shannera Reed wrinkly says that since Ryan's, when there's been like a backlash,
um, basically, I mean the next year another black team broke through.
It was two black women this time and not caused this big controversy and people
were saying that the state of debate was ruined and in that same year you even
had a group of schools like talking about breaking off to form their own
tournament where performance styles wouldn't really be invited.
I think all of this just makes Ryan like not really know how to feel about his
win.
Like maybe sometimes it can just for him feel like an anomaly.
Yeah. It sort of seems like there's a series of accidents here.
You're in a school where accidentally you have a teacher who pushes you pretty
much forces you into something which suddenly takes you over.
You turn out to be peculiarly good at it almost again by accident.
Then you're thrown into the sequence of events where you get to meet Elijah,
and then almost by accident you become a champion and then suddenly it's over.
The whole thing feels strangely lonely to me.
Lonely but beautiful. But I wonder how it feels to you. Ironically,
the thing that is the first time you have agreed with Robert this entire
interview, oh, stop.
Just gotta give him a hard time versa.